in smash there are plenty of ways to
beat your opponent you can play it safe
and eke out a win or you can style on
them and show them what you're really
made of but there's only one way to
truly dominate your foes a zero to death
taking someone from 0% to dead is one of
the hardest things any player can do it
requires wreathed patience and a mean
combo game so today we want to highlight
those achievements here are the top 10
0-2 depths in smash kicking off our list
at the number 10 spot is a zero to death
from an old legend no one expected much
from the shiz was coming in to smash
summit 7 and although he wasn't able to
make it far in the tournament he gave
the fans a taste of his glory days by
landing one of the cleanest Falco zero
two deaths you'll ever see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was actually best the number nine
spot on our list is a zero - depth that
showcases just how good Terry can be
whenever a new DLC characters release
and you just start slapping everyone a
week when a new character comes to smash
you can never know what kind of insane
potential could be unleashed and that's
be a mukha smash cup riddles gave
everyone a taste of what Terry can do
just ten days after the King of Fighters
character was released I wonder if you
do downside the - tag I don't think in
Canada it's slower than Rios but it's
very sit that with - ex-deputy similar
Wario's man they say you don't Amelie
down throw up there Emilia kinds of this
power dunk off the top platform got
about a head smash no way took his jump
dead did coming in at number eight is an
ultimate point but if you didn't know
better you'd swear you were looking at
melee don't park on the grass 2018 with
smash Ultimates biggest stage yet and
players from all over came to test out
just what their characters were capable
of in this new and exciting game and for
Falcon players that meant showcasing new
ways of creating the most hype possible
in ultimate and big V well he showed us
just how hike falcon can beat he's been
doing this for years
[Music]
bringing the knee and the crowd is
popping off big t do it in oh my god at
number 7 on our list is a zero to death
that stomps on the terror list who is
this guy
what are we watching right now I did
Ganondorf isn't exactly a high tier
character he's big he's slow and he's
basically a worst Captain Falcon and
every way possible but that doesn't mean
he can't dumpster other characters when
cannon Dorf is doing his thing he can
tear you apart and delete your stock
before you even know what's happened and
that's exactly what bizarro flame did to
strain and Kings of Kali 4 with stomp
after stomp after stomp
that's nice really nice down and now
that wasn't good that was good good
gainer off edge guarding is pretty tough
you gotta get over sides without face
neonscar looks already in the lead now
[Music]
no way who is this guy
what are we watching right now I did huh
two seconds ago he was an even match the
number six spot on our list is one of
the many iconic moments from the kid
mango specifically his iconic double
dunk on a lesson at the big house for
mango has proven time and time again how
flashy Falco can be as a character and
at the big house for he's crazy style
was on full display as he pulled off one
of the greatest losers runs in smash
history sure mango won the tournament
but what everyone remembers is how we
put the bird to work against the leffen
in the losers finals creating a play we
now know simply that's the double dunk
really amazing air dodge by mango yeah
awesome presence of mind by left - but
it just went mangoes way at that time
the detail of a chance to check with the
side - he said he should have just down
at him yeah hold up I guess coming up at
number five is the moment smash players
realize that those impractical combos
you see on Twitter all the time could
actually be done in a real match after
an initial zero to death combo that was
deemed too broken by Nintendo standards
Luigi fans were forced to head back to
the lab to find new ways to elevate
their character but a Genesis black the
perennial Luigi mein elegant showed
everyone his true potential with a zero
to death that made fans everywhere
rejoice Larry fighting all these
characters where it's like oh I'm up
100% oh hold on is this all you think of
it there's prize
[Applause]
Larry just thought like a Ken and like
if that's exactly what Ken does to you
and then now he's fighting another
character that like oh I'm in 0% like
I'm fine right question mark and you
just get at our number-4 spot is of
course one of the most iconic smash
plays of all time the wombo combo
[Music]
[Music]
folks you already know this one pours
ooh happy feet wombo combo get your ass
whooped those words echo in smash
history but besides the commentary this
play is a tasty example of how stylish
you can make a zr2 death look in a
two-on-one situation unfortunately for
zoom he's on the butt end of this whole
ordeal Wars ooh you've already seen
mango on one side it was here to death
so Yuri is on the other because coming
in at a number 3 spot is Armada
systematically destroying mango our
motto was actually retired during beast
3 but the way he was playing during the
exhibition's against mango you'd never
know it
the Swedish sniper systematically
destroyed the kids Fox
[Music]
[Music]
it ended up as a brutal force talk but
in terms of zero to deaths you won't
find a more clean-cut precise and
destructive stock out there in our
runner-up spot we have not one but two
of the quick is zr2 deaths you'll ever
see
courtesy of axes Pikachu and better yet
you're getting four stalks for the price
of one that was emphatic that was
amazing
mortality are you watching axe versus
silent wolf at Evo 2014 is one of the
most iconic matches in smash history
not because it's a tense post match but
because axe annihilated his opponent he
was probably bounced to avoid the chain
grab and I kind of like the fod counter
pick per match because where the player
has technical as sound wolf and the
change in high school platforms can
really do a lot i'm messing him up
potential stocks gets beat up erred sale
spike and suit at that
[Applause]
nice light shield not even trying to get
shield stuff as the shields do get
really small other stock big gotcha
he gets to zero to deaths back to back
then proceeds to for stock silent wolf
hole in under a minute between D ones
iconic commentary and axes incredible
feat this is a match smash fans will
never forget taking our number one spot
is a moment that embodies the word hype
in every way possible this is a
statement right here at b6 westballz
wasn't a whole other level showing us
moves and gameplay we had never seen
from him before and in the losers finals
against leffen for just one stock
westballz showed the absolute peak of
Falco play percentage where's Castle
turnaround crap what his boss is
absolutely going up right now
why did that bird oh this is a statement
right here West Pope isn't doing all
this stuff cuz he feels he needs to do
if there was a 20xx for falco i think
it's safe to say he hid it so that's our
list those are the top 10 smashed zero
to deaths and if you think we missed one
or you have another idea for a smash top
ten list let us know in the comments and
if you want more great smash videos like
this one then throws us up really does
mean a lot thank you so much for
watching everybody I know I usually
mentioned this up top but we are all
shooting from home right now due to
concerns are out kovin 19 but I want to
give you a behind-the-scenes look at my
awesome recording setup which is my
closet like my shirts are here and my
girlfriend's clothes are there and my
underwear is in one of these drawers you
don't need to see that look I look
insane right now but the fact the matter
is these are the links we're going to to
keep making amazing video for you guys
so thank you for subbing thank you for
watching and I have another top ten to
voice in my closet and my girlfriend's
very mad at me